this video is about the story of elven ring this
will cover all the important characters relevant
to the main story including most bosses and
some npcs as well as explain what happened
before we arrive in the lands between who we
play as and what the endings of the game mean
sections of this video are separated via
chapters located on the timeline should
you need to re-watch a specific section again
as always spoiler warning ahead if you haven't
beaten Elden Ring i highly recommend you do that
and then come back as everything after this point
will be spoiler territory with that out of the way
like the video if you enjoy and let's get started
so the location of Elden Ring is in a place called
the lands between this is a land ruled by a Queen
Marika it was once ruled by a dragonlord but it
said that when its god abandoned them they sat in
slumber awaiting their return which left the spot
for the ruler open this title was given to her by
someone known as the greater will when you become
the ruler of the lands between you also become a
vessel for the Elden Ring the Elden Ring is the
single most powerful thing in the lands between
its power is what created the Erdtree and it is
meant to uphold different concepts like life death
space and many others it also defines the logic
of the world called the golden order which is a
law the residents of the lands between abide by
the greater will is an outer god and it's said
to have sent down a star that held a beast that
would later become the elden ring the elden beast
the final boss of the game is defined as a vassal
for the greater will and the living embodiment of
the concept of order to become the ruler of the
lands between the ruler will need three things
they need to be an emperian and must have a
consort and a shadow a consort is just the
spouse that they marry who in Marika's case
was godfrey a shadow is the protector of that
ruler and an emperian is someone who is born
from a single god talking with Ranni towards
the end of her questline reveals that her
Miquella and Malenia are considered emperians
let us speak of the past a while i was
once an emperian of the demigods only i
Miquella and Malenia could claim that title
each of us was chosen by our own two fingers
as a candidate to succeed Queen Marika to become
the new god of the coming age that means there is
a clear distinction between a demigod like Godrick
and an empyrean like Malenia, Malenia Miquella and
Ranni are still considered demigods but there is
that empyrean part of them that separates them
from the rest the question though is how is this
possible so when Marika became the first ruler she
wasn't fond of the idea of death in her land so
she removed the rune of death from the Elden Ring
and forced it onto her shadow who was Maliketh
instead of protecting her as the shadow would she
betrayed him and just used him as a way to keep
the death away from her land with the rune of
death out of the elden ring it allowed Marika and
many others to gain immortality shortly after this
she needed a consort who would then be Godfrey and
now that Godfrey was her husband he also received
the title of Elden Lord making him the first Elden
Lord this isn't entirely true as there is a lore
that does suggest the very first elden lord was
possibly Dragonlord Placidusax that we fight in
Farum Azula but i think either no one knew of
the dragonlord or Godfrey was the first Elden
Lord during his own age which was the age of the
Erdtree which was much later than when Placidusax
was Elden Lord regardless Godfrey and Marika had
two kids which were Godwyn and Godrick this is
easily identifiable thanks to the god prefix
and their names there were more kids besides
them but more on them later during this time war
had been going on against the golden order and
another person named Radagon had been involved
in the conflict but decided to usher peace by
marrying Lady Rennala Queen of the Carian royal
family when the two were together they ended up
having children as well being named Radahn Rykard
and Ranni once again all of them start with an
r just like Radagon and Rennala's first name after
the war had finished it was said that the hue of
Godfrey's eyes had faded possibly meaning he had
served his purpose and was no longer needed as
soon after he was exiled and became the very first
tarnished but now Marika is without a consort so
she sought out Radagon Radagon then left Rennala
and joined Marika at the Erdtree and became her
new husband and the new Elden Lord and since
he was an Elden Lord his children by proxy were
allowed to be a part of the royal family which
is why they have thrones at the royal capital
despite not being Marika's offspring once again
Radagon and Marika were together and they had
even more kids that being the twins Miquella and
Malenia this may stir up some confusion as i just
mentioned that an empyrean has to be born from
a single god yet Ranni Miquella & Malenia were
all born by two parents well as we discover later
in the game Marika is Radagon there's a statue in
Leyndell that has a riddle that says regression
alone reveals secrets by using the spell laws of
regression in front of the statue it changes its
form and the text changes to Radagon is Marika now
i'll be completely honest it has never explained
how this happened and what exactly this means and
it's probably the biggest question that has been
unanswered so far in the community some have come
up with some theories regarding this such as the
two being separate entities who refuse together
somehow or it's one body that suffers from
dissociative identity disorder however the other
question that remains is who was first although
i do believe there is an answer to this given the
empyrean status and the greater will giving her
the lands between i think Queen Marika was first
but this riddle now explains why Radagon left
Rennala for Marika and why Miquella and Malenia
are considered empyrean since their parents are
the same person which then fits the rules of
that one god stipulation this has been quite the
family tree so a huge shout out to JustamBlingon
on reddit for creating this easy to read graphic
the only outliers here at the moment are Marika's
parents but seeing as she's an empyrean it's not
as simple to answer plus we get zero info on her
parents anyway but besides them the only one left
is Maliketh Marika's shadow and the keeper of the
rune of death according to his armor description
Maliketh is actually her half-brother who wielded
a blade imbued with the rune of death this is a
good time to explain this as if you noticed from
the actual description it says destined death
well the finger reader at the round table hold
clarifies that the rune of death goes by two names
and the other is destined death the rune of death
goes by two names the other is destined death the
forbidden shadow plucked from the golden order
upon its creation for simplicity's sake unless
entirely necessary i will refer to it as just
the rune of death to avoid any further confusion
the final character of this family tree we haven't
thoroughly talked about is Ranni earlier in the
game a witch known as Renna meets with us however
this is Ranni she's just using a different name
in order to disguise her identity Ranni was born
under Rennala & Radagon two separate people yet is
considered an empyrean it's still not clear as to
why this is the case but my only working theory
is that Rennala is her adoptive mother but we'll
discuss that in the boss's chapter regardless
it's not that big of a deal anyway since she
didn't want to be an empyrean this sequence of
events would eventually lead to the shattering
depending on who you ask the shattering
might be considered the greatest war
ever fought or the worst tragedy the land has
ever seen Ranni wanting to be anything but an
empyrean worked against marika the greater
will and the two fingers and devised a plan
one day she stole the rune of death from Maliketh
with that power she created daggers able to kill
the demi-gods on that same night called the
knight of the black knives a group of assassins
called the black knife assassins would kill the
first demigod Godwyn it's also interesting to
note here that according to the black knife armor
description all of the members of this group were
women and they're all rumored to be Numen which
you may remember as one of the default races in
the character creation they also have close ties
to Marika which may mean that Marika is of Numen
descent it doesn't really give us much regarding
her backstory but it is worth knowing anyway
back to the intro when Godwyn was killed he had
a mark on his body this is considered the curse
mark of death an item we could receive during
Ranni's questline this curse mark appeared
the moment Godwyn was killed but this symbol
however is incomplete as it should have been
a full circle the reason it's only half is
because two demigods died at the same time
breaking the curse into half circles the other
god was Ranni herself as Ranni says she wanted to
strip away her empyrean flesh so that nothing of
her was related to the two fingers both of these
demigods had the opposite happen to them Ranni's
body was dead but her soul lived on and Godwyns
soul was destroyed but his body survived this not
only explains why Ranni's new body is a doll but
also why Godwyn was seemingly reborn after he was
killed godwin was given the name the prince of
death because of this encounter and is related to
Fia's questline where she tries to resurrect him
after hearing the news of Godwyn's death Marika
possibly in a fit of rage shattered the Elden Ring
one thing to remember of course is the distinction
between Radagon & Marika because Marika's hammer
reads the tool with which Queen Marika shattered
the Elden Ring and Radagon attempted to repair it
this is once again left up to the community to
decide as it's never explained but my working
theory and furthermore my theory between Radagon
& Marika is that originally they were separate
people but something fused them together possibly
the greater will in regards to the shattering
situation i think each of them despite being
the same person act differently which explains
why Marika specifically broke the ring and why
Radagon specifically is trying to repair it with
the shards of the Elden Ring scattered everywhere
across the lands between all the demigods were
attempting to gather all the shards the intro
then shows a slideshow of some of the demigods
like Mogh the lord of blood taking Miquella away a
serpent biting a helmet which is related to Rykard
symbolizing how he became the lord's serpent and
then the iconic fight between Malenia & Radahn the
problem is that during this war nobody won the
land was stuck in a stalemate with the demigods
that were left standing holding pieces of the
Elden Ring but nobody was close to owning all
of them this stalemate left things unchanged
and the land was covered in ruins with some
areas like Caelid being covered in rot and disease
furthermore none of the demigods are making moves
on each other as they preferred to defend their
land rather than fight to take others land and
subsequently the shards so something was needed
to break this stalemate which is where we come in
we are called Tarnished during the age before
the shattering called the Age of the Erdtree the
golden power of the Erdtree would drop down from
its branches and spread across the Lands Between
it blessed many throughout the land but also
refused to bless others for an unknown reason
these people were considered tarnished those who
aren't worthy of the Erdtree and are looked down
upon by the eyes of the Golden Order this exile we
received is similar to Godfrey's exile as he was
deemed useless by the greater will and the Golden
Order which is symbolized by him losing the golden
color in his eyes we are deemed unworthy by the
greater will so it has no use for us in the Lands
Between which means we're considered Tarnished
and are forced to leave but when the shattering
occurred the Lands Between was in disarray and
because it still wanted to hold onto its power
the Greater Will bless the previously exiled
Tarnished in hopes that it will return and
restore the Golden Order it was even able to bless
many Tarnished who are dead like us of the other
tarnished the important ones listed in the intro
are Hoarah Loux chieftain of the badlands the
brilliant Gold Mask Fia the deathbed companion
the loathsome dung eater and Gideon Ofnir the
all-knowing our objective as this new Tarnished is
to cross the fog back into the Lands Between stand
before the Elden Ring and become the Elden Lord
the key here however is Elden Lord not the ruler
meaning we are never meant to usurp Marika from
her position merely bring the runes together so
that everything can go back to normal confer great
rules to become Elden Lord and join Queen Marika
as her consort the fingers have willed it so this
however did not happen thanks to us committing the
very first cardinal sin later in the game which
was the burning of the Erdtree and more on that
a bit later so as a tarnished resident of the
lands between we are eagerly ready to take on the
demigods until we're killed by the first enemy we
face but we are somehow able to get back up again
avare right at the beginning of the game explains
that the guidance of grace the same light that
guides us towards the bosses in game is what gives
us tarnished life meaning it can revive us it's
also possible that the rune of death also affects
us too since the removal of the rune made people
immortal in the lands between which may explain
our revival for those who don't know most if not
all the soulsborne games always had a reason as
to why death was canon so it's hard to believe
that it wouldn't exist in Elden Ring too. after
exploring the lands between will run into Melina
the girl from earlier in the intro she tells us
that she will become our finger maiden since we
are maidenless except later she apologizes that
she isn't actually a maiden so she offers us a
deal if we can continue to work with her and bring
her to the foot of the Erdtree so that she can
meet with her mother and discover her purpose she
will continue to act as our maiden and allow us
to level up there's a lot more to melania's story
but i'll save that for later when we discuss the
endings after some time she will then introduce us
to the round table hold the covert operation base
for the two fingers and a place where tarnished
champions guided by grace can reside most of them
however don't seem too keen on becoming elden lord
in fact it only really feels like us and gideon
are really working towards that goal many of them
just seem to want to save shelter away from the
danger outside according to Gideon we aren't
going to get a proper welcome into the round
table though until we defeat a shardbearer and the
first one we can defeat is Godrick but before we
meet Godrick we have to talk about Margit Margit
The Fell Omen is a recurring character in the game
as he not only shows up again in the altus plateau
but also shows up at the foot of the Erdtree under
the name Morgott The Omen King earlier i talked
about children we haven't discussed yet and that
is Morgott & Mogh if you remember from before
we talked about how Miquella & Malenia are twins
this is the same with Morgott & Mogh Godrick's
great rune says that Elden Lord Godfrey and his
offspring were the very first demigods and that
line of children was known as the golden lineage
Morgott's rune says that he was a part of this
golden lineage and Mogh's grey rune says that
him and morgan are twins so it makes sense that
they're a part of the lineage together however a
curse inflicted both of them omen babies born of
royalty do not have their horns cut but instead
are kept underground and imprisoned for eternity
it seems that they were permanently chained as we
can find an item called market shackle which is a
small part of a few larger shackles that were made
to bind Margit Morgott once again also known as
Margit was cursed but it seems like he didn't hold
any ill will against the golden order as despite
never being loved by anyone he still continued
to give out his own love and become the Erdtree's
protector as for his twin during his imprisonment
Mogh was sought out by someone only known as
the formless mother the formless mother is an
outer god similar to the greater will but with
more sinister plans he by the will of the formless
mother was attempting to make Miqeulla the new
ruler of the lands between he would then rule
as his consort and the formless mother would then
be able to control the lands between just as the
greater will can now Miquella and Malenia once
again were twins born from Radagon & Marika and
since they're the same person this fit within the
rules of them being an empyrean this explains why
Mogh wants Miquella as the ruler and not himself
because he isn't an empyrean according to more
item descriptions the formless mother only seeks
out those of a cursed blood which is why he was
chosen it also seems like he couldn't just make
Miquella become the ruler right away because
Miquella hasn't achieved full godhood yet it's
unclear why but it could be related to Miquella's
own curse something we'll discuss a bit later
getting back on track after Margit we can meet
with Godrick the grafted Godrick grows to power
through the act of grafting according to Rogier
he states that there are tarnished hunters in
this castle that will take our corpse to Godrick
so that we can be grafted to him it's clear that
Godrick ruled his castle with fear as not many
would dare oppose him out of fear of becoming
a part of him so it's quite hilarious when you
return to his arena and find one of his servants
kicking his corpse repeatedly Godrick was a feeble
old man with no real power but he wanted to prove
to the others that he deserved the title of lord
by using fear and manipulation to get his way but
it's quite obvious that he's bluffing as without
the grafting he's barely even a competent fighter
our next boss we meet is the Lady Rennala Queen of
The Full Moon The Academy of Raya Lucaria was at
odds with a group called the Carian royal family
both practiced different versions of Glintstone
magic and attempted to be the better sorcerers
but due to the age of the Erdtree many of its
residents in the lands between found power
and hope in the golden order making glintstone
sorcery useless the royal family then withered
away during this time and so did the academy but
it wasn't until the shattering that the academy
had a resurgence in power in her youth Rennala
became a prominent champion who charmed the
academy with her lunar magic she also commanded
the glintstone knights and established the House
of Caria as royalty however despite being a
champion and a renowned sorceress she became
heartbroken thanks to Radagon leaving her she
then became a shell of her former self and it was
only then that the academy members discovered
that she wasn't a champion after all later the
academy would then rebel against the Carian royal
family then lock her away in the grand library
shortly after this the shattering would occur so
the academy was permanently locked down as no one
wanted to participate in the shattering so they
were left out of the destruction upon entering
the grand library we can see a ton of kids as well
as Lady Rennala holding an amber egg in her arms
after defeating her first phase Ranni starts
speaking saying that we're trespassing and are
not allowed to disturb her as we know Ranni is
the daughter of Rennala but this doesn't make a
whole lot of sense though as Ranni is an empyrean
who was born from two parents which leads me to
believe that Rennala is the adoptive mother
and not the birth mother of Rennala regarding
this whole sequence i also think this was a spell
casted by Ranni just in case anyone had intentions
of harming Rennala not only is the boss arena
completely different but right after defeating
her again we can see that she is just lying on the
ground this leads me to believe that this spell
was an illusion made by Ranni so that she could
protect her that egg she carries however is the
last thing ever given to her by Radagon before he
left it seems to also have the power of rebirth so
either she is holding on to this item because he
gave it to her and it's quite precious to her or
she's possibly waiting for the eventual rebirth
of Radagon through this egg i hope it's not the
latter as that wish won't come true since Radagon
is clearly alive regardless of its significance
it's clear that Rennala still hasn't gotten over
her ex-husband and has been ruined because of it
she is no longer the queen of the full moon and
is barely even a sorcerer anymore during her boss
fight the kids are actually more troublesome than
she is with her only attack being the occasional
chandelier falling after fending off the illusion
we then can return to Rennala who gives up her
great rune and offers us a chance to respec our
stats seeing as we have the great rune and she
is clearly in no state to fight there's no reason
to kill her so we just let her live our third boss
is Radahn who resides in Caelid a land that has
been infested with scarlet rot thanks to Malenia
and her curse Radahn is considered a champion
of the shattering and may have one of the best
backstories in this whole game when Radahn was
younger he looked up to Godfrey as he loved how
strong he was in battle so when Radahn was able
to wear his own personal armor he had a chess
piece made with a line on the front to symbolize
Godfrey's beast region Serosh he also looked up
to his father who was proud of his accomplishments
so he grew out his long red hair and wore it with
pride as he grew older he started taking after
these two figures in his life and wanted to
become as strong as they were but whether it was
because of genetics or the amount of strength he
received during this he started growing in size
this troubled him as due to his size and weight
he wouldn't be able to ride his horse that he's
had for his whole life so he went to Sellia in
Caelid which is called the town of sorcery it
was there where he learned gravitational magic
and was able to manipulate the ground around
him and be able to call swords to his hands
but more importantly he was also able to affect
his own body weight meaning he could ride his
horse without crushing it we know this not only
because we can see him do many attacks while using
gravity but the symbol for gravity magic is the
same symbol on his swords furthermore it's known
that the elden ring commands the stars just as
it commands the other concepts of the world like
life and death but general Radahn is considered
the star scourge and seems to be able to control
the stars this is because the cutscene after his
death has all the previous stars held in the sky
by him come crashing down one of which actually
lands right near us causing a massive explosion
but the difference between general Radahn and many
of the other boss fights is that it's not a normal
boss fight as upon entering Caelid making our way
to the back of the castle we can see that there is
other people here Blaidd and Alexander are here
assuming you met with them prior as well as other
characters we may meet in the future like Okina
Lionel and Targoth the reason they are here is
because they're all participating in the radon
festival a once in a lifetime opportunity where
you can face general Radahn in battle and claim
his great rune we can summon all these people
to fight with us including many people who weren't
there for the festival such as a finger maiden and
even patches the organizer of the festival gives
us a backstory of Radahn and his current state is
not too great if you recall from an old trailer
Malenia & Radahn fought at this very place
well during this fight Malenia pierced Radahn
injecting scarlet rot into his body do you
remember earlier when i said that the twins
were cursed well whereas Miquella is cursed to
an eternal childhood never becoming anything older
than a boy Malenia is cursed by being forced to
harbor a rot with inside her body all the rot in
Caelid is most likely because of her we can see the
effect that it has on her face in limbs but when
we get to phase two of the boss fight we can not
only see how much of her body's been affected but
also how much control she has over this disease
getting back to Radahn she ended up using this rot
to corrupt him now he is just a blood-hungry beast
but the only thing on his mind about what his next
meal is going to be and what the next kill will be
this festival seems to have been created by
Radahn himself or by an organizer trying to
help Radahn Jirren is the name of the organizer
here at the castle and after defeating radon
he thanks us for the fight as not only was that a
spectacular battle but we were able to give Radahn
his final wish which was to die an honorable death
he couldn't stand the current state he was living
in and wanted someone to end his life but it would
be dishonorable for a general like him to die from
suicide or surrender so an honorable fight to the
death was the only way for him to feel at peace
but now that general Radahn is dead there is only
one rune left Praetor Rykard is a unique case in
the world of the lands between he lies at the
bottom of Mt. Gemlir the location of the
most appalling battle in the shattering Rykard
committed the grave sin of blasphemy he spoke out
against the golden order as he was bothered by the
greater will and the golden order's willingness
to just cast aside those deemed unworthy for no
reason many people would flock to reichard in his
castle the volcano manor but people started having
doubts about his decision a spirit near the castle
is seen atop a pile of bodies in pain and says
that if he had known that this blasphemy would
have caused this much destruction he wouldn't
have tolerated his decision given that many of
those in the land between believe in the golden
order it's quite obvious why many would hate
Rykard and his followers as they're actively going
against what they preach this probably led to many
crusades against Rykard which negatively
impacted the livelihoods of all his people
upon entering the manor we can meet Tanith she
then asks us if we've ever harbored any doubts
about the guidance of grace and the golden
order and if we do say yes then she'll invite
us to the volcano manor family she goes on to
explain that the tarnished were blessed with grace
like everyone else in the lands between but it's
clear that the tarnished didn't get their fair share
record refused to bow down to this and believes
that if the Erdtree would debase them then they're
willing to go against the golden order even if
it's considered heresy so as a member our job
is to seek out those who are aligned with the urge
tree and the golden order this is in the form of a
few npcs we are tasked with invading but the manor
also gives us a recusant finger which allows us to
invade other players worlds so all the players we
invade are technically the tarnish he speaks of
which is why we're tasked with eliminating them
after a few contracts have been completed upon
coming back we see a spirit sitting in the corner
he's preaching to the manor and in hopes someone will
heed his words he wants us to eliminate the great
serpent the one who devoured prater Rykard
seeing as it was him against the whole kingdom
since everyone disagreed with him and continued
to align with the golden order printer record
required more powers that he may fight on an even
level this is when he met the great serpent it
seems that the serpent promised him power as long
as record was willing to be eaten by him record
agreed and became the lord's serpent thankfully
this spirit has given us a way to defeat him by
letting us know of the power that resides in the
serpent hunter a weapon specifically designed to
kill the serpent the fight is quite trivial with
this weapon as it should be but during his second
phase he pulls out a sword and as we can see from
the weapon it has moving hands which were all
from his previous victims it's quite sad to
think about all the people in their past lives
and accomplishments now being withered down to
nothing as now they're just a part of the serpent
family stuck in this hell forever we can actually
talk to some of the members of the volcano
matter after defeating Rykard and none of them
seem upset Bernahl believes that the strong take in
the weak suffer so by killing him we proved that
Rykard was weak Tanith even agrees and thanks
us for showing them how weak a record really was
the only problem is that record's immortal it just
takes time for him to get back to full strength
and should we return to the boss arena we can see
Rykard's body repairing itself while Tanith holds
him so it seems that riker will eventually come
back how long that will take is unknown but just
like before we have the great rune so currently
our job is done with all the great runes in our
possession we can travel to Leyndell the royal
capital and go to the Erdtree here is where
we meet numerous knights and tree sentinels
truly showing how powerful this army really is
there is also a one-to-one version of the round
table hold in here this is most likely the real
round table and the one we're taken to is just a
copy since the shattering ruined much of the land
and caused this residence to close off its walls
as we remember only certain people can enter the
round table it's not a building that people can
just waltz right into which may explain why on
the map the round table hold is off to the very
side symbolizing that it's separate than the one
in the lands between on top of this since we made
it to the capitol Melina leaves our side since we
fulfilled our deal and brought her to the Erdtree
but when we ourselves get close to the Erdtree
godfrey attempts to stop us this is clearly a
spirit version of him and it's possible given the
golden color that it's godfrey's remembrance from
during the war before he was tarnished all the
remembrances we gather in game are memories of the
bosses and these memories are all a part of the
erd tree later in the game we will actually end
up fighting godfrey in his actual form but when
we defeat him he drops the remembrance of Horoah Loux
not the remembrance of godfrey which leads me to
my previous conclusion after him is when we meet
Morgott and since we already discussed him quite
a bit i won't repeat myself however he does let
us know who the thrones are for which was Godrick
Miquella Malenia Radahn Rykard and Ranni he also
calls them all traitors which is quite interesting
i think it's because Morgott believes that they are
fighting so they can claim the power of the Elden
Ring for themselves and become the new Elden Lord
but Morgott being the protector of the Erdtree finds
this a disgraceful act as it's clear that they
only really care about the power that comes with
the Elden Lord title and not about protecting the
Erdtree and the golden order after defeating
Morgott we can talk to him momentarily and he calls
us a fool saying that the Erdtree doesn't open
for anyone and that no one will be able to claim
the title of Elden Lord and it seems that Morgott
himself tried to attempt this and wasn't allowed
inside to prove his statement we walk up the steps
and discover we can't enter the earth tree has
rejected us the year tree is covered by impassable
thorns that cannot be cut Melina then arrives
again and explains to be elden lord we must pass
through the thorns and the only way to burn them
is to go to the snowy mountaintops of the giants
and use its smoldering flame to set the er tree on
fire we can then talk to the finger reader back at
the round table hold to get more insight on this
and she goes on to explain that because of this
sudden turn of events which is us being rejected
by the Erdtree the two fingers is currently
consulting with the greater will but we likely
won't get an answer for thousands of years we then
tell her our immediate plan to burn the thorns
and is shocked by the idea claiming that the snowy
mountains is not a place for mere men and that
burning the Erdtree is the first cardinal sin
something the fingers and the greater will will
never agree to furthermore we then explain our
next step in the process which is to unleash the
rune of death when we make it to the highest point
in the mountains, we talk with Melina who tells us
that she will be the kindling required to burn the
tree earlier the finger reader told us that this
ritual requires a sacrifice and Melina is willing
to be that sacrifice before she disappears though
she does deliver a few words and goes on to say
that throughout her life she has seen death and
discrimination everywhere convincing her that
the lands between is in dire need of repair this
sort of implies that she has lived quite a long
life something that connects to a theory of mine
later in the game as we touch hands once more she
takes our power and uses it and the smoldering
flames nearby to create a flame big enough to
set her and the tree ablaze afterwards we wake up
in Farum Azula not much is known about this
place but i believe this was the temple in the sky
throughout the lands between are ruins of a fallen
city the ruined fragments we pick up are believed
to be a part of a temple in the sky and the only
place in game that fits that description would be
Farum Azula as we explore the area we run into
the beast clergyman again the same one in Caelid
who we give the deathroot to assuming you've
followed through with that quest line he then
attacks us since we are clearly here to steal
the rune of death from him and he doesn't want it
stolen again this is a nice piece of foreshadowing
as soon after defeating him he reveals his true
form to be Maliketh the black blade the shadow of
Marika and the owner of the rune of death now it
makes sense why we were feeding him deathroot
during his questline as the description reads
after the death of Godwyn the rune of death spread
across the lands between through the underground
roots of the great tree sprouting in the form of
death root Maliketh being the owner of the rune
of death would obviously want his power back so
by consuming the death root we are giving it back
to him upon his death a weird object sprouts from
his shadowy ashes this is the rune of death
and because it's unbound the lands between
are now shrouded in a dark fate and the greater
will is not happy about that we pass out again
and awake in Leyndell but now it's covered in
ashes it seems like we have a straight path to
the Erdtree now but nothing is ever simple in
this game blocking our path is Gideon & Godfrey
Gideon appears in Godfrey's chamber and the
long-awaited fight ensues Gideon and us have been
gunning for the elden lord position all game so
it was only a matter of time before we faced off
together except that's not what's happening gideon
immediately says that nobody will become the elden
lord and that Marika has plans for all of us and
that plan being that we struggle for eternity so
why this sudden change of heart Gideon during his
journey to obtain all knowledge may have uncovered
some details about merica that changed his mind
the all-knowing helmet description reads knowledge
begins with the recognition of one's ignorance
the realization that the search of knowledge is
unending but when Gideon glimpsed into the will
of Queen Marika he shuddered in fear at the end
that should not be something terrified Gideon
so much that completely changed his mind about
being the elden lord my guess was most likely the
relationship between the greater will and Marika
or maybe even the Elden Beast as well as for
Godfrey he appears in normal human form this
time and we can see him holding more god in his
arms Godfrey then spots us and recognizes us
immediately as the tarnished warrior the one who's
been conquering many before him Godfrey wants to
obtain the Elden Lord title again and since that
conflicts with our goals we have to fight him
after half his health is gone he uses Serosh to
gain more power and reveals that his true form
is Horoah Loux the chieftain of the badlands when
Godfrey and the other tarnished had been forced
out of the lands between this act was called the
long march and when the long march had finished
Godfrey and the other tarnished had started their
own civilization and it was during this time that
godfrey possibly wanted to cut all ties away from
him in the lands between so he adopted the name
Horoah Loux however with Godfrey finished nothing
stands in our way when we enter the room we see
Marika chained to a part of the elven ring
but eventually, she breaks free but her hair
turns red and we realize that Radagon is now in
control it seems to me that their bodies change
when one takes control as Marika and Radagon seem
to have different physiques when viewed up close
like Marika having a skinnier body in the absence
of breasts when Radagon is in control this may not
be entirely true however since it's quite hard to
look at their bodies while you're being attacked
but this at least confirms that there are two
people in one body however we still don't know
if they were two separate people that then became
one or if it was always one body to begin with
after the fight is over Radagon starts becoming
engulfed in a black mist as a hand reaches out
and takes him underneath the pool of sludge out of
this sludge arises the Elden beast probably one of
the coolest looking bosses in the soulsborne
franchise we've already discussed the Elden
Beast in detail earlier but as a reminder the
Elden Beast is the vassal for the greater will
and is the living embodiment of the concept of
order but the question is why are we fighting
Radagon and the Elden Beast in the first place
remember the point of our journey was to become
the Elden Lord and be a consort for Marika so
why are they killing the one person who was able
to fill that role one is possibly due to the
fact that we are tarnished and even attempting
to become elden lord does go against the golden
order but it may also have to do with the greater
will and a secret agenda that it has it's clear
that the greater will wants Marika as the ruler
of the lands between and to have the elden ring
repaired to the golden order can be stable again
but since that stalemate occurred it needed help
which is why it called the tarnished back to the
lands between the greater will more than likely
had a plan in mind but since we burned the Erdtree
and unbound the rune of death it most
likely casted all of that aside and just
opted to kill us as we committed a cardinal sin
regardless of its intentions the elden beast is
defeated and the greater will seems to have
no power over the lands between anymore it's
unclear whether or not the greater will is truly
dead though or if its power is truly gone as the
elden beast is just a vassal for the greater will
which is much different than a vessel Marika is a
vessel for the elden ring whereas the elden
beast is a vassal for the greater will so it
acts in accordance to the greater will's wishes so
i think the greater will still does exist in some
way but doesn't really have as much control over
the lens betweens as it used to with the elden
beast slain we now reach the ending of the game
and it's here where i have to be a bit honest with
all of you i don't know all the endings of elden
ring and depending on when you watch this video
you don't either despite what many believe there
is in fact more than four endings in the game
and at the time of making this video there is a
total of six confirmed endings with a seven still
under investigation, i normally don't make these
videos until everything has been discovered so
we can get the full picture but this could take
an undetermined amount of time to figure out so
if you'll forgive me i'd like to discuss these
endings with all of you anyway so the very first
ending is the default one that all players will be
able to obtain which is the age of fracture this
shows the player mending the body and runes back
together and becoming the elden lord like we set
out to do the lands between seems to go back
to normal but is a fractured version of what
it once was thanks to the shattering and all the
demi-gods we slayed on our path here the next three
endings are all tied to character quests and are
the same ending but with slight alterations in two
different places the age of duskborn is from
fia's questline where we use the mending rune
of the death prince she provides us at the end of
her questline as a way to mend all the runes back
together but instead of it being a normal looking
pattern the curse mark appears at the bottom
and instead of a normal looking sky there's a
grey mist that covers the land this seems to imply
that the rune of death is back in the elden ring
which hasn't happened since before Marika's reign
meaning the death will come to the lands between
once more and immortality is a thing of the past
the blessing of despair is the third version of
this ending and is activated upon completion of
the dung eater questline and using the mending
rune of the fell curse which leaves a sizable
clump of disease on Marika's body the land once
again changes but to a brown and reddish tint
and possibly implies that the dung eater got
his wish he has a dream of blessing the people
with a curse that starts with all the people he's
defiled and killed they will then be reborn and
create children who harbor their curse and those
children will have their own children who harbor
that curse until everyone is afflicted by it the
fourth variation of this ending that we know of is
the age of order which is done by completing
brother Corhyn and the Gold Mask questline
where on the body of the gold mask will be the
mending rune of perfect order needed to complete
this ending just as before it's the exact same
ending with the same differences this rune is
of a transcensional ideology that will attempt
to perfect the golden order this is symbolized
in the pattern being the same as before but with a
large circle around it as for the differences the
sky seems to be the same golden color but now the
erd tree is golden once again our last two endings
are different from the ones we have discussed so
far the lord of frenzied flame is the opposite
of the other endings that we just discussed
where the tarnish will become the lord of chaos
they then burn the Erdtree and most likely leave
the lands between to do this you must complete the
quest route of the three fingers which ends with
the three fingers grabbing and marking you however
depending on when you do this another cutscene
will play it's done after Melina sacrifices
herself then the ending plays out like normal but
if you're marked upon arriving Melina leaves your
side and promises that if you go down this path
she will have no choice but to hunt you down now
if you choose this ending every other ending is
locked unless you use an item called Miquella's
needle which reverts the marking allowing you to
choose the other endings again this is why she
mentions that part about going down the current
path is we do have the option to change our mind
but assuming we don't and Melina knows that we're
marked a second cutscene will play where Melina
grabs what is presumed to be the whistle we use
to summon torrent and then vows to hunt us down
we also see that her left eye is now open and has
a purple color to it whereas the right eye that
is used to be yellow is now faded this has led
many to believe including me that Melina in some
way is related to Ranni in the story trailer for
the game Ranni is seen with the right eye closed
then the left one open and the spirit form next to
her has her left eye shut and the right eye open
but it's the same eye which is the trailer
possibly telling us that these two beings
are related and the only person with her left eye
shut throughout the game is Melina this could also
explain why Melina seemingly appears wherever
we are as the spirit form she is just able to
teleport in and out of existence the final ending
is called the age of stars and it's available upon
the completion of Ranni's questline we summon
Ranni from inside the Erdtree where she then
picks up and places Marikahead onto her body
just like we have done in the previous endings
she then goes on to make a promise to all the
living beings and souls that exist in the world
and says that the age of stars has commenced and
that the one thousand year voyage underneath the
wisdom of the moon is about to begin possibly
meaning that the people are no longer bound by
the forces of a god and can act on their own free
will we then become her spouse and she becomes the
new ruler but you may be asking how was that
possible as while ronnie was an empyrean she
claimed to have stripped away her impurian flesh
so that can't make her a ruler well there is a lot
to unpack with this ending and is quite difficult
to interpret given how little we actually have to
go off of but it seems that ronnie wants to have
the moon and stars under control again as it's
possible this was the large governing force
of the world before the greater will arrived
this would make sense given that she wanted to
break away from her empyrean body and since the
greater will is out of the picture this concept of
empyreans is unnecessary now this is what leads me
to my previous conclusion that the people of the
world will no longer be bound by the influence of
a higher power and can think on their own these
are all the endings we have so far the seventh
one dubbed the age of absolute is still under
investigation others are also trying to figure
out if it's possible to do the age of star ending
with Melina still alive just to see if something
changes since of course the growing theory is
that they are related however at the time of
making this video none of this has gotten anywhere
so we'll have to wait and see with that however we
come to the end of Elden Ring and subsequently
the end of the video the amount of lore in the
soulsborne games is astronomical and trying to
catalog all of it then repeat it to an audience
is incredibly challenging but i think i did a
good job providing a clear and simple timeline
of events for all of you feel free to watch any of
my other story explained videos on different games
in the industry or if you prefer to listen to a
review rather than a retelling i made a few videos
discussing the stories of specific games like the
bioshock series and fallout 4 that you may enjoy
with that like the video if you enjoy and
subscribe if you're new and thank you as
always to my returning viewers for coming back
to another video take care everyone and goodbye